When learning about recursion, it can seem
like you're always going back to the beginning.
In this course, the simple engineer will help
you understand recursion using animations,
thought processes, and more. Hey, guys, and
welcome to another video brought to you by
the simple engineer. In today's video, we are
going to delve deep into the depths of recursion,
and strengthen your algorithmic mental model
around this programming paradigm will do so by
looking at a variety of different examples
and animations. So let's get right into it.
The first question that we have to answer about
recursion is what even is recursion? And I think
the best way to talk about it is through this
analogy, and let's imagine that you're sitting in
line waiting to withdraw money out of an ATM. And
for the sake of this example, let's assume that
this right here is you and you have this question
this underlying question. And you want to know
how many people are standing in front of you in
this line. And this kind of brute force, iterative
version of you says, Well, what I can do is I
could step out of line, I could run to the front,
and I can maybe, maybe count one by one. And maybe
I store these counts in some auxilary, you know,
notebook that I have some external variable that
you can imagine, and then you run down this line,
and you get back and you say, Okay, I got my
answer. But I did a lot of work. And we want
to kind of switch this paradigm, we want to think,
how can I be lazy? What's the least amount of work
that I can do, and sort of break this problem down
in some sort of sub structure? And so what I do
well, I tap on this girl's shoulder in front of
me, and I asked her a very simple question, I say,
hey, what number are you? And she turns around
and looks at me and says, you know, I'm sorry,
I don't really know. But what I'll do is I'll ask
the woman in front of me. And what happens is,
this process kind of continues, and it continues
up until we hit some stopping condition. And this
condition that we get stopped at is when we hit
this woman, and she taps on this guy's shoulder.
And he says, she says, hey, what number are you in
line? And he gives this response. And he's number
one. And this is interesting, right? Because this
is kind of the stopping condition to this sort of
problem that we were solving. And what she does,
if she takes that number, and she says, Well,
if he was number one, then I'm basically
one plus one, because I count myself.
And this guy says, Well, if she was number
two, that I'm one plus whatever she was,
and this idea unravels backwards to the original
asker. And this woman basically says to the guy,
hey, there were, you know, 10 people
in front of me, I count myself.
And now I'm at 11. And it turns out, that we can
model this problem with this simple blueprint,
we ask the first question, what's the least
amount of work that I can do? How do I break
this problem down into some sub problem?
And the second question that I have is,
when would the process complete? Like, what's
my stopping condition. And in this case,
it's when we hit the first person in line, which
is the gentleman withdrawing money from the ATM,
it just so happens that we can actually write
this problem in a very simplified, minimal,
beautiful piece of code. And the function that
we have is just this get my position in line. And
we have this kind of abstraction of a person
that we have. And notice the return values in
integer. And, again, if we think back to those
two questions that we have for this blueprint,
we say if the next person in line is null,
then we must be the first person in line.
Right? That's kind of this base case, imagine
nobody is in line, well, then you're probably
the first person in line. Now, if we don't satisfy
this conditional, then what do we do, we do just
a little bit of work, we say, I'm going to count
myself as somebody that contributes to the number
of people in line. And I'm going to add this
kind of recursive call, and I'm calling myself.
And this is the interesting property
of recursion, we're calling our self.
But the parameter that we condition on actually
further progresses us to the problem that we're
trying to solve. And so I'm not I'm not passing
the same person object into the function again,
I'm actually passing a person that progresses me a
little bit closer to the question that I'm asking,
which is, how many people are in front of me. And
this is really all recursion is about is how can
I take some large problem and break it down into
a bunch of subproblems such that each invocation
of my method gets me a little bit closer to the
problem that I'm trying to solve? Let's think
about another example. Let's take back to the the
school days where you're writing a bunch of essays
and typically this process, at least for me, is
you know, you writing So you submitted to your
professor and he says, Hey, you know, that essay
was terrible, I want you to go make revisions.
And the essay gets passed back to the student.
And this process can actually continue over and
over and over again, you write an essay, you
make revisions, you submit it, it gets denied,
and you rinse and repeat. And you do this
until the professor says, Okay, that was good,
I'm going to put it into my briefcase, and start
grading it. And it just so happens, this, again,
is this kind of recursive strategy that can be
developed. If we look at a simple piece of code.
And what are we doing, we're really, we look
at an essay, we revise the essay, we read it,
we get feedback on it, we apply changes to it.
And then notice, we just call ourselves again,
right. And there's a single base case
kind of hidden in here. And we do it
until the essay is complete. And notice
that each invocation is the same essay
object. But what we've done is we've inched
our way a little bit closer to that goal,
that goal of no longer needing revisions
on the essay. So the whole process again,
just to re emphasize is that we do a little bit of
work on each invocation of our method call Intel,
we hit some base case, some stopping condition
that says, hey, you no longer need to continue.
So again, like what is recursion, recursion is
nothing more than a method that calls itself
and to be more precise, it's usually a method
that maybe returns a value, maybe it doesn't.
But it's conditioned on some parameter, such that
when you hit some conditional at some point in
time, you can actually stop recursing, some base
case, right. And we consider this piece the base
case, this is the stopping condition, such that
we no longer grow the number of recursive calls
that we're storing in memory. And this piece down
here, this is the recursive call. This is where I,
you know, I do some unit of work, some small sub
problem that inches me or progresses me closer
to the goal or question I'm trying to
answer. Before we dive into the technical
intricacies of recursion, it's important
that we discuss some of the trade offs.
Why would we want to use recursion? And
why would we want to avoid recursion.
And I think there are valid examples for both.
And it really comes down to the situation.
The first pro that I'll give is that it really
bridges the gap between elegance and complexity,
we will look at a variety of different
problems where we're traversing
complex data structures like trees and graphs.
And it really boils down to three or four lines of
code. And that is vastly different than doing
something like that, in this kind of imperative
approach, where we're, we're looking at things
with a lot of loops and a lot of variables. And
that can get really messy really quickly, with
data structures that are inherently recursive.
Now, on the downside, you know, adding a bunch of
method calls on the call stack incurs some
CPU overhead, right, there is some slowness,
with calling methods in your code compared
to iterating through a loop. And that, again,
is another trade off you need to make it can be a
time or space trade off that you need to consider.
Now, I touched on this briefly, but again, like
recursion can reduce the need for complex loops,
and auxiliary data structures. recursion has
this sort of implicit stack, which is a data
structure commonly used in a lot of algorithms.
And so having that sort of implicit stack and
kind of self manage looping construct, it's
given to you as a part of recursive calls,
you can exploit that property to really simplify
your code and focus on the problem you're solving.
Now, the con for that is as you're
growing the amount of method invocations
in your computer memory, you can actually run out
of memory. And we'll look at a lot of examples as
to why this is, and we'll, we'll start to explore
this, this idea of a Stack Overflow exception. And
this is where we start to run out of
the pre allocated buffer of memory
that we have for our program, which can
actually cause your program to crash.
There are a lot of pros when it comes to recursion
when talking about optimization, reducing time
complexity. And that's what this idea of memos
zation, and we'll look at some examples of
memorization and caching, to help speed up
redundant calls. And that's a beautiful property
of recursion. Now, the con again, just like any
piece of code, is that if recursion is overused,
you can get into this sort of habit where
you start to develop really complex code,
if it's not well instructed,
and you want to make sure that
and what we'll get a lot better at this
as we go through this This tutorial
is when you look at problems, you want to
kind of ask yourself, Is this a good use case?
For recursion? Can I really break it down into
subproblems that make sense for recursion?
If you cannot, then you may get into this con
where you have unnecessarily complex code.
Now, the final thing, as I had
mentioned before, is recursion
works really well for recursively defined
data structures, JSON objects, trees, graphs,
things that allow you to basically focus on
one tiny unit of the data structure at a time.
And it just so happens we'll look at a bunch of
different examples as to why this holds true. But
this is just a small set of pros and cons, things
to consider when thinking about using recursion.
This brings us to a topic that I think is
often overlooked when teaching recursion,
which I think is one of the fundamental
concepts that you really need to grasp
to understand what people
call quote unquote, magical
about recursion. It's just magic with how
it works. And after we look at this example,
we'll start to realize how logical recursion is
and why it's not necessarily such a magical thing.
Let's imagine that you go to work one day, and
the first thing that you want to do is check your
email. And whilst checking your email, you get
interrupted by your boss, and your boss says, Hey,
I need you to go attend some meeting. And
you have to actually deviate from your task.
So you don't finish checking your email, you get
interrupted. And before you can check your email,
now you need to attend this meeting. Now, let's
say your boss, well walk into this meeting,
your boss interrupts you again. And he
says, Hey, our investors are visiting,
I would love for you to go to this board meeting
and impress them with all your knowledge. And
so again, we'll walk into this meeting, you get
interrupted, you have to go impress the investors.
Right, that's your next task. And so before you
can attend the meeting, before you can check
your email, you need to impress these investors.
And finally, your boss, he interrupts you again.
And he says, Hey, you know, I'm sorry. But I need
you to go help Jake with his code, his code is
failing. And we need to push to production. So now
you have to basically avoid the investor meeting,
avoid the initial meeting, you can't check your
email until you help j code. Once you help him,
this thing kind of gets popped off your to do
list, you know, you go to the board meeting,
you attend this original meeting. And
then finally, you can check your email.
And you may be asking, like, why is this ever at
all relevant to recursion. And it just so happens
that this sort of idea is exactly how the call
stack works when we're talking about invoking
methods within our programs. Let's take a
look at this simple program here. Notice
we have three method calls. And they're kind of
chained together. The first one returns a string,
but it has a dependency on B, B returns
a string, but it has a dependency on C.
And c just returns a string. So nothing fancy at
all. Now, the call stack is going to be this sort
of abstraction that our operating system leverages
to store method invocations within our program.
It allows us to understand what memory addresses
we return data to, and it stores local variable
information, like what are the parameters
that were passed into me. So if we execute a,
the first thing that goes on to the call stack
is this sort of idea known as a stack frame.
And it basically says, Hey, I want to call
Hello, and I want to concatenate the result of B.
But in order for me to concatenate the result of
B, I need to actually now call B. So that pushes B
onto the call stack. Now I'm in the same scenario,
where I want to now return from B, but I have a
dependency on C. So now I call C and put that
on the call stack. And notice this is the same
sort of process that we looked at in the
previous analogy. I cannot return or pop
these things off the stack until I kind of go in
the order in which these things were called. So
I returned friends, right. And now friends
replaces that see invocation. And so now
this has been fully evaluated. And so now since
B is fully evaluated, I can return that value
to the B method invocation. And now that
B stack frame gets popped off the stack.
And it's only at this point that I have now
evaluated that entire chain of method calls.
So now I can return this string
value. And get my expected output.
Now you may be asking, like why still? Why
is this relevant to recursive thinking.
And let's look at an example. Let's look at a
call stack when we call these recursive calls,
right? This is just a program that
calls itself and it'll execute forever,
right? So the first time I invoke a will now
I need to invoke a, but it calls a again.
And it just keeps happening, right?
There's no stopping condition. And finally,
there's going to be this point, this point
in time where I try and invoke a again,
and I get a, I get an error, and
that error is a Stack Overflow.
And this exception happens when we exceed the pre
allocated buffer of memory that our program has.
Right, we basically have run out of
memory, we've exceeded the stack,
and our invocations have overflowed,
and we can no longer handle it.
And this is the whole thing with recursion, why
we need a base case, we need to return a value.
So just like we saw previously, for methods
that aren't recursive, we noticed that frames
still grow and grow and grow. And the only
way for those frames to shrink in size
is for them to return some value for them to
stop invoking methods. And the same holds true
with recursion. The only difference is, we have
some sort of base case something that says, hey,
this is the one thing that I want to condition
on to avoid us from further recursing.
I want to start off the first technical component
of this presentation looking at recursion with
strings. And this is going to give us a really
good idea of manipulating input parameters on
the call stack recursively. And the first problem
I want to look at is this idea of string reversal.
And so what we do is we have an input string
like the symbol engineer. And the idea is the
output would be the input in the reverse order,
right? And so the question is, how do we how do
we build a really concise recursive function that
gives us something like this. And as we look,
as we look at the skeleton structure for this
code, we of course, are going to have some sort of
input, right? So the input is going to be some
string, and the output is going to be the reverse
version of that. And so we always ask kind of
these two questions. The first is, what is the
base case? And this is really asking, when can I
no longer continue within my algorithm? And the
next line of code is going to be all about what's
the smallest amount of work I can contribute?
So in this case, it's going to be basically
between each invocation, what's the small
unit that I can actually modify or manipulate
to progress a little bit closer to the goal?
So let's look at the first question. The first
question is saying, When can I no longer continue?
And I think I think when you think about this sort
of scenario, there are two schools of thought.
And when I when I like to construct base cases,
I typically think if I were to just pass in a
very small input, like what is the smallest
input that I could just pass in to start
to this function, where I would need to basically
immediately return. And there could be two schools
of thought with this approach, right? And the
two schools of thought could be, well, one letter
reversed is itself, right. And that could be a
really, really good base case for string reversal.
But we want to be even lazier. Like what is the
laziest, like the least amount of work that I
could even consider thinking about. And that would
be the empty string, the empty string reversed,
is again, just the empty string. And so if I
passed in the empty string to this function,
and it would only make sense
to get the empty string back.
And so if we, if we modify the code, and we
look at this, we just have a simple base case
where we evaluate if the input string is the empty
string, then let's just return the empty string.
But now we need to consider how do I even
get to that point? What's the smallest amount
of work that I can contribute? Right? And
that's the question that we're asking here.
I need to do something that whittles down the
decision space within each recursive call.
And so we kind of asked this question, what's the
smallest unit that I can deal with in a string? A
string is just a bunch of characters, right?
And so maybe I can modify a single character.
And this is where we get to this question. Let
me pick a single character out of this string.
And maybe where I position it will allow it to be
concatenated from the call stack in the reverse
order. And it turns out when we when we write
this code, we get a recursive call where we,
we take that first character from the input string
and we concatenate After the recursive call,
and you may be looking at this and you say, Okay,
well, the input parameter has changed. And it's
changed because we've actually shrunken down the
decision space, we've shrunk in that input string,
because our entire goal is to get closer to that
base case, right. And so we've taken everything
directly after the first character to the end.
And the idea is that if we do this enough times,
we can shrink our search space on each invocation
and get the goal, which is the reverse string.
So this first piece is all is all focused on
shrinking the problem space. And the second piece
is reflecting really the work that we're doing to
contribute closer to the goal. And I think it's
worthwhile to analyze what is happening on the
call stack. So let's say that we pass in Hello.
And we don't hit the base case, on line two, we
immediately go to line six, which is basically
the recursive invocation with the shrunken down
substring. And then we concatenate the H. And just
as we had discussed with call stacks, we can't pop
this off the call stack until that recursive call
has also completed, which adds an
additional stack frame to the call stack.
And you notice, again, we don't hit the base
case, and we shrink down that input string,
but we concatenate the first character. And we
keep doing this. And it's nice, because I don't
need to keep track of the H, I don't need to
keep track of the E. It's all self managed for
me in the stack frame on the call stack. And so
I invoke reverse string again. And now I get Oh.
And now watches this gets fairly
interesting, because as I pass in,
oh, I get to a point where my input string has
been whittled down to just the empty string.
And it just so happens that for this use
case, this is the base case. So I return
the empty string. So that reverse
string gets evaluated the empty string
from this base case, and I end up just
returning the empty string plus Oh.
And now this recursive call gets evaluated. And
now I add L. And this just becomes o l, right.
And so now I can return this. And
this gets popped off the call stack.
And now you can see that I'm basically returning
these values to the stack frame that preceded me.
And popping things off the call stack.
This function gets evaluated in ADS II.
So I return it and pop this off the call
stack. This function gets evaluated to o Ll E.
So I return it, it gets evaluated. And then
this gets popped off the call stack. And as
you can see, this is the goal, right? This is the
reverse string. And it's the power of the call
stack the power of these recursive calls that
allow us to return values back down the stack.
And this is a very good property that
we can exploit when using recursion.
Let's look at palindromes, palindromes are
these unique words, where we can basically
spell the same word forward and backward.
Let's look at this word. The mechanical
way that we kind of analyze if a word is a
palindrome or not, is we look at both ends.
And we basically say okay, do these letters match?
Yes, they do. So we shrink in Word, we say do
these letters match? Yes, they do. So we shrink in
Word. And now this is just one character. And it
proves that we've we've matched successfully.
So this indeed would be a palindrome.
Now let's look at a snippet of code to see how we
could think about something like this recursively.
Now, obviously, we're going to have a
Boolean function, because it's either Yes,
it's a palindrome or No, it's not. And
we're going to evaluate some input string.
And of course, the first thing we always consider
is what is this base case, the thing that stops us
from recursing? Now, think back to what
I had said in the previous example,
I always like to consider my base cases, what
is the smallest input that I could just pass
into this function? And it turns out very
often not very often, for string recursion,
you can typically whittle down your search space
and evaluate the input length. So if you passed
in a palindrome that was of size zero, then
that's a palindrome, right? Because there's
there's nothing that proves it's not a palindrome.
There are no characters to compare against.
And in the same vein, if we pass in just a single
character, with a single character, both forward
and backward is the same character. So that's also
a palindrome. So these are really good use cases,
or base cases to evaluate this conditional,
which is whether or not a string is a palindrome.
But let's continue we need to
consider the small amount of work
that we can do. And in the animation that we just
looked at, you notice that we had two pointers,
one on the left and one on the right, and we
were comparing those strings, those characters,
we're saying they need to be the same. If they're
not the same at any point in time, then we've
violated the property of a palindrome. And if we
violate the property of palindrome, then we just
go to this false. This is kind of this fallback
base case. So at any point in the algorithm, if
the characters don't match up at their respective
opposite indices, then we can terminate,
we return false and the false gets propagated
through the call stack. And the initial color
function would return the false. But if that's not
the case, then we get to this interesting thing,
where we call this recursive call, and it whittles
down or sub our substring. So let's look at the
call stack to understand what's happening. We
pass in race car as an input string. And this
of course, is a palindrome you can see race
car forward and backwards, it's just race car.
And the first thing we do is we evaluate
this, this conditional this base case,
is the length zero or one? Well, it's definitely
not. So we continue. And now we compare the
first character and the last character for
this input string. And if they're equal,
then we just call ourselves again,
but we shrink that input string.
And since these since R and R are equal, we
add another stack frame to the call stack.
And we've shrunken down our input string,
we again, look at the base case, we don't
satisfy it. So we compare the first and the last
character. And we notice in this in this case,
they're also equal. So we call ourselves again,
right, and we don't pop the stack frame off the
call stack, because we still have more work
to do. And so we shrink down our input string,
we still haven't satisfied the
base case. And our characters
at the first and last position are still the
same. So we do just a little bit more work.
And now we're at the last character. And
we've already come to this conclusion that
if the input length is zero or
one, then we just return true.
So for this one particular subproblem, this one
particular element, this is indeed a palindrome.
So what do we do, we say, yes, this was a
palindrome and we pop it off the call stack.
And since we return true, and all of these other
conditionals have been satisfied, that we can just
propagate through the true Boolean down the call
stack. So we return true here and pop this off.
We go to the next stack frame and return
true here and pop this off. And now we
get to the final stack frame, which evaluates
to true. And this gets popped off the stack.
Now I want to look at recursion with numbers.
And the thing that you'll start to realize as
we go through these sorts of problems, is that
the same blueprint holds true for all of them.
And the first problem I want to look
at is this idea of converting decimal
base 10 values to binary, which is a base two
number format, ones and zeros. So the question is,
how can we convert a number like
25 into its binary counterpart.
And it turns out, there's a very mechanical way
of doing this. So let's take the number 233.
And the formula here, as we'll come to find
is we can do a division by two and this is
basically doing the floor operator. So it gets
us an integer instead of a floating point value.
And we get we get an output, which is 116. And
we have a remainder, and that remainder is one.
And the mechanical process that we can
follow to convert decimal to binary is
we take the results of this operation,
which is 116. And we divide that by two.
And we just keep evaluating, and this is 58,
remainder zero, and then we take 58. And we
divide that by two, and this is 29, remainder
zero. And we basically just keep taking the
result in the output and dividing it by two. And
notice we're keeping track of the remainders here.
And the interesting property by doing these
operations gets us to a point where we can
take all of these remainders. So notice, we've
gotten to this base case, which is zero. And that
kind of halts this progression. So now we're
done. And if we take all of these remainders,
in the order that they were basically pushed onto
the stack, we can evaluate them and this is the
result in binary string for 233. And the question
is, how can we Okay, this this mechanical process,
you know, very formulaic? How can we
convert it into some recursive operation?
Let's take a look at some of this code. Now,
notice, we said the first thing is we took 233
divided by two, we got some output The remainder
was one. And so there are actually many ways
of doing this problem. And we're going to keep
it really simple. So notice we're dealing with
strings. As the result outputs, we're going
to be concatenating strings basically.
And so what we consider here is we we think
about that base case, right? If I hit zero,
then there's no longer reason for me to
divide further, right, I return my result.
Now, if I have not hit zero yet, it means that I
still have more division to do. And so the first
thing that we do is we get that remainder. So
when we look at 233, divided by two, we want to
store that remainder because that represents
one of the binary digits that we care about,
basically tells us if the value is
even or odd. And this is the binary,
this is the remainder that will contribute to
the result. And so that's why we store this
in the result. And notice, we just prepend this
to the result. And now what I do is I again, just
call find binary and I shrink my problem space
by half. And I just propagate the result through.
Now let's let's actually look at the call
stack. By coding this. And seeing what it
looks like I want to take the code that we
were just looking at, but look at it from
the perspective of the call stack and understand
how these stack frames are building up over time.
Now, there are many ways to code this fine binary
function. And a lot of people do it returning an
integer. And that's completely fine. And if you
want to do it that way, you can actually follow
along with any modification of this and analyze
the call stack with me. So as we run in debug,
the call stack is going to show up down here. So
these are all the stack frames that we can watch
grow. And the variables on the current stack
frame will show up under here in local. And so
as we dive into this function, you notice that
this is the first stack frame for find binary.
And in order for this to complete,
we need to return some value.
We haven't hit our base case yet. So we jump into
our work. And we just make another recursive call.
So the first stack frame can't pop off yet,
because we're going to invoke ourselves again.
And once we do that, you notice
that we add another stack frame.
And also notice that the input parameters have
changed. We've shrunken down our decision space,
and we've appended the first digit to our binary
result. We haven't hit our base case yet. And we
continue. And again, we do a recursive operation.
And our decision space keeps shrinking. And this
is the same mechanical process that we saw in the
animation, we divide by two and log the remainder,
we divide by two and log the remainder. And we
do this until we hit some sort of base condition.
Right. And as we shrink down our problem
space, notice we get to this point where
the decimal is one. And that still is
not our base case. So we go through,
we get the result. And this binary string
is looking pretty good. In on the final
recursive call, you notice the decimal is
now zero. And this is a really good case now,
because now we can just return. So we
come in here and we return this value.
And this value comes in and says okay, find binary
for that invocation returned this result. And so
now we're just saying, okay, continue. And notice
as I step through, the stack frames have grown.
But now they should shrink off the call stack. So
I step through. And notice they've all shrunken
down, so all of them have returned, they've all
returned a value. And now once I step over here,
we noticed that the binary
value has been evaluated,
you can come into this debug
console and look at it.
And this is the resulting binary string. And so
it's good to look at how the call stack is working
to understand. Okay, how many stack frames do we
build up to get to our result? And how do they
unravel once we hit our base case here, we've just
straight up propagated the result down through
all of the stack frames, and all of them just
return the same thing. And we'll look at a lot of
different examples where all the stack frames kind
of work together. And they wait for the result to
do a little bit more work. And so there's a lot
of different versions of this. The next problem
that I want to look at with numbers is the sum of
natural numbers. And the idea of this problem is
you take an input number like 10, and then you sum
all the values up to 10. And what we do here is we
actually just add them all up, and we get some
output and the output in this case would be 55.
And the question is how can we build some
succinct function that Does this recursively
Now let's look at a little snippet of code and try
to understand what's happening behind the scenes.
So recursive summation, again, we take in an input
value. And the first question we need to ask is,
what is the smallest input value that I could
pass in. So if I pass in one, for example,
the sum of one to one is just itself. One,
right. And so that's a good, that's a good place
for the base case. And again, keep in mind, we
are simplifying these functions. So you know,
edge cases, we're not really focused on that.
Right, now we're focused on the core goal,
which is building a succinct function. So
if I pass in one, I would return one. Now,
if I pass in a larger number, like 55, I still
have a lot of work to do, I need to add up
all the proceeding numbers up to 55 from one. And
so what I can do is I can take whatever value I am
currently. And I can add it to myself again,
but subtracting one from that numbers, right.
So it shrinks me closer to this base case. Let's
again, look at some code and understand how the
call stack is working with this sort of code. So
I've taken the same code from the slide. And now
we want to look at the call stack and understand
what's happening as we make these recursive calls.
The first thing that we'll look at is the number
five, so we want to add all values from one to
five. Let's put a breakpoint here and debug into
the call stack. So as I dive into this operation,
we first evaluate the base case, which hasn't
been hit yet. And so now what I want to do is
I want to take five, and I want to add it to
another recursive call, but that recursion
is shrinking down the input space again. And
so as I dive in, notice this input number
change. So I make the recursive call, and
the input number has shrunken down to four,
and another stack frame has been added to the
call stack. And so we keep evaluating has the
conditional been hit? No, it has not. So I
come in here and it shrinks down to three.
And I keep doing this, and I come in here. I
come in here. And now the input number is one
has the base case been hit yet? Yes, it has. And
so if I dive into this, you notice that we return
one here. And this one returns this
value to the stack frame right below it.
And so notice that as I continue, that stack
frame gets popped off. And you can see that the
invocation of this method returned one here. And
so now what I'm doing is I'm taking two plus one,
and I'm returning this value and
this value is going to continuously
unravel through these stack frames. So
notice, all of these get popped off.
And here's the final invocation, the input
number is 10 here. And as we continue,
this is evaluating for recursive summation of 10.
And so now again, for 10, we get down to a base
case. And that base case is one. And if we look,
so I'll put a breakpoint here. And we continue, we
can see that we have the results of 15 and 55. And
these get printed out. And so again, this is just
an example to show as we're looking at the stack
frames, how a stack frame can return a value to
its previous stack frame to finish the operation.
And that's the key here for recursion. And we'll
keep doing this for a lot of the problems that
we look at to get familiarized with how the call
stack is working, and how the stack frames grow.
I want to talk about divide and conquer
algorithms, which are really great demonstrations
of recursion. And the blueprint that we think
about for dividing conquer holds through so
we you know, still divide a large
problem into several small problems.
But divide and conquer is all about we divide
them into subproblems. We independently solve
them. And then we actually merge the
results to solve some holistic problem,
right? We merge them together and say, Hey,
this is the solution. And they are typically
recursive. And let's look at the first one,
which is binary search. And the entire purpose
of binary search is we look at a sorted list of
numbers. And the key point here is they're sorted.
And let's call this array. And the first
thing that we say is we say alright,
I'm going to start with the left and right
index, so the far left index is zero and the
far right index is the length of the array minus
one. And the whole purpose of binary search is to
find a value we want to find a value in this
array. So we know that zero is less than the
length of the array. So we can Have not hit
our base case and we calculate the midpoint.
So the midpoint is the left and right index added
together and divided by two. And so we check, we
say, okay, is that midpoint? The answer that we're
looking for? So that's another sort of base case,
have we hit or found the number 10? Here? And the
answer is no. So we ask one of two questions, the
first question that we ask is, is the number that
we're looking for on the left half of the array,
or is the number that we're looking
for on the right half of the array.
And remember, we just found the midpoint, so
we're considering everything to the left and
the midpoint and everything to the right of the
midpoint because the input data is sorted. Now,
if it's on the left half, which is what we're
looking at here, then we completely discard
the right half. And notice, the way that we do
that is we change the bounds of the problem.
So the left half stays the same. So our
starting point on the left stays the same,
but we only consider up to the midpoint minus one.
And so that is our ability to shrink our decision
space and completely discard the right half in
each recursion, or each recursive invocation.
Now, if we get to this other evaluation, this
is basically saying the value we're looking for
is on the right half. And what this allows us to
do is we only consider our starting point to be
the midpoint plus one all the way to the
end. So we completely discard the left half
for the rest of this problem. And
this indeed, is also a recursive call.
So look at the first stack frame in the
call stack to the right, we start with zero,
our upper bound index for the right variable is
nine. And the number we're searching for is 10.
So here's our midpoint, this is
three. And we asked this question,
Is this the value that we're looking for?
Is this 10? And the answer is no, it's not.
So what we can do is we can discard the
entire left half of the search space because
10 is greater than the midpoint. And it turns out,
we add another stack frame to the call stack and
notice how the parameters have changed. Now for
the left, the starting bound, which is the left
is five, which is the index where four is,
and the upper bound is nine, which is the
original length of the array that we're working
with. And again, we calculate the midpoint,
the midpoint on this sub array is nine, and we
say is 10, greater than nine or less than nine.
And of course, we know 10 is greater than nine.
And so what we can do is completely discard
the left half of that sub array and continue. And
we add another stack frame. And the stack frame,
the start bound is eight in the upper bound is
nine. And we again, recalculate the midpoint.
And the midpoint at this point actually turns
out on line seven, we've hit this base case,
the base case here is that we've found
the number that we're looking for. And
this is the solution. And so what
we can do is just return this value.
But we're not done yet, because we need to still
consider the call stack. And so this value is 10.
And so what we do from this stack frame is we
return 10. And in this case, we returning the
index that 10 is app. So 10 is at the eighth index
of the array, and this gets popped off the stack.
And now this binary search invocation has been
completed, and it gets eight. So it just returns
eight. And this gets popped off the stack. And
now finally, we return eight. And we're complete.
And the final stack frame gets popped off the
stack. And that's how binary search works. Let's
look at Fibonacci, a classical, mathematical and
computer science problem that often demonstrates
the power of recursion. And we're going to
be looking at the non optimized version here.
And we'll add some optimizations at the end. And
let's look at the mathematical expression. First,
we're basically saying that for some input in at
the index n is going to be made up of the sum of
the two values at the two indices that precede it.
Let's look at the Wikipedia page for Fibonacci.
And this is the sequence the Fibonacci sequence.
And if we take one of these numbers like 55,
it's the sum of the two numbers that
preceded so 34 and 21. And if we look at 34,
it's the sum of 21 and 13. And if we look at 13,
it's the sum of eight and five, etc. And this,
this formula holds true for all values of one to
infinity. And so this is the Fibonacci sequence.
So if we look at this expression again, now we
have these base cases in pink, and basically says
that for the values of at index zero and one,
the base cases are zero and one was Effectively,
and we can just return at that point. So that
would be where we stopped that recursion.
And the piece of yellow is just saying that this,
this holds true for all values of one to infinity.
So let's let's kind of look at this and
understand why it differs from the previous.
Now we're dividing and conquering, right, we're
dividing this problem, we have fib of n minus
one that needs to happen, we add it to fib of
n minus two. And these are two recursive calls.
And as we think back how the call stack works,
we know that the recursion on the left needs
to complete before we even considering, consider
starting the recursive call on the right. So fib
of n minus one could have a ton of different
calls that need to complete before we even do
the plus operator to fib of n minus two.
So let's look at how this would animate.
So we want to find the Fibonacci of five. And like
I had said, we do not evaluate the right hand side
of the expression yet, because we need to satisfy
that first recursive call first. So this gets us
F, fib of five minus one, which is four. And
this gets us four minus one, which is three.
And this process continues F of two. And remember
our base case, f of one is just one, so we would
return from here. And now to can evaluate the
right hand side of its recursive operation.
Remember, we're calling the same function over
and over again. So now we've hit a base case,
we've evaluated the left hand side, which is
fib of n minus two, or fib of n minus one. And
now we can do fib of n minus two for this value,
which is f of zero. This again is a base case.
So we can return from here. Now, the sum of these
two values return and get passed up to F of three.
And now F of three can evaluate its recursive
call on the right hand side of that plus operator.
And again, we do f of one, that's a base
case, so we just return it. Right? Now this,
these F of two, f of one get added together to
return from F of three, and this gets passed to f
of four. And now F of four can evaluate the right
hand side of its expression, which is f of n minus
two. So here we get F of two. And again, this
recursive property holds true, this is a base
case, we return it, we evaluate the right hand
side, this is a base case, we return it. And
now this gets propagated back up to F of four. And
these values get propagated back up to F of five.
And it's from here. Now, this is the very first,
you know call of the function, we can now evaluate
the right hand side of that plus operator. And
again, we get down to f of three, we get down
to f of two, and then this is f of one. And
this is a base case. So we return it and this
is f of zero, this is a base case, we return
it. And notice like we're doing the same thing
over and over again, this gets returned. Now we
go to the right hand side, this gets returned,
this gets passed up. And now we can add these
two values. And that's how we find the Fibonacci.
Now, we'll look at optimizations for this later.
But I just want to point out one thing like as we
evaluate this, notice, we have f of three here,
we have f of three here. This is redundant,
right? All of the nodes below F of three are the
exact same. And so it seems extremely wasteful,
that we're recalculating these values. And so as
we'll come to realize, there are optimizations
that we can consider to avoid recalculating
something that we've already done the work for.
So if you look, we have f of two, f two and
f of two. And this is three nodes. And you
can imagine for really large numbers,
it turns out for Fibonacci, you know,
most modern day computers cannot run Fibonacci
for this function at a very high input. And that's
because the recursive calls are so intensive. So
we have to look at some optimization techniques
known as memoization. Merge Sort is this poster
child of divide and conquer when explaining this
in a lot of computer science classes. And the
idea is that we take in a bunch of unsorted
values, like the following. And the idea is
that we divide this array in such a way that we
keep dividing. And then we merge up the sorted
results to sort this array in ascending order.
And it kind of looks like this. So we split the
array in half and we say, Alright, I'm going
to focus on the left hand side. And remember,
before I even do the right hand side, I need to
finish the left hand side first, right? That's the
order in which recursion is going to operate here.
And this process just holds through. So this is
the left hand array and what do I do I split this
in half. And now I decompose this into two parts.
But again, I first have to focus on this half. And
then I can focus on this half. So I look at, you
know, I split these, and I look at foreign one.
And the base case here is that you
can't really soar just one value.
And so I can stop splitting when I hit
just one value. And I compare these two,
and I merge and sort them together
just by a simple comparison operator.
Now I can look at the right hand side, and I
basically split these. So I have one integer here,
and I take two and zero, and two and zero gets
split even further. And again, I'm down to this
case where I just have digits, and so zero to
get compared, they get merged up. Now three has
a linear time comparison, again, zero and two,
and these get merged together. And now we take
one and 402, and three, these get merged together.
And now I've solved the left half of this array.
But remember, now I need to do the right half,
we're evaluating in the order that recursion
would consider this. So when we split this, I get
the right half of the array. And I do the same
thing on this side. So I take this array, split
it, I get negative one and seven. This gets split,
I compare them. And it just so happens, they were
already in sorted order. So these get put back in
the same spot. Now I take the right half of the
array, right, and I split this even further.
And so when this gets split, I
have 10, nine and 20 gets split,
nine and 20 are individual digits. And when I
compare them, they are already in sorted order.
And then I compare all the digits here,
and they get merged back in sorted order.
And then again, finally I compare these digits,
And this brings us to the final merge,
remember divide and conquer is all about
dividing your problem into subproblems.
And then merging the results together.
So what we've done is we've just recursively
merged all the results together from the
recursive sub calls. And this is the final merge.
And just to emphasize how this comparison works
to ensure that these things get put back
in sorted order, we do a linear comparison.
And what that means is we basically have two
pointers, starting with the left hand side
and we say alright, which number is smaller, and
we know negative one is smaller, so we put this
in its spot and increment the pointer. And then we
compare these two values will zero smaller here.
So we put that in spot and increment the pointer.
And we keep doing this as we compare values.
And notice here, we've actually run out of
values in the left hand array. And since
we already know the right hand array is sorted,
we just placed these back in the positions they
belong. And as we look at the resultant array,
we noticed that Merge Sort has sorted the input
completely. And so this right here is the sort of
solution. And now the question is, how do we build
something like this? How do we devise a recursive
algorithm that could construct a sorting,
you know, solution to a problem like this,
we're gonna look at some code to do that.
So we have a blank slate here. And we want to
consider how Merge Sort would work to satisfy the
properties that we looked at. Now, the first thing
I want to do is build the recursive call. And so
remember, Merge Sort takes in an array, and it
sorts it. And we're going to do this in place. So
I'm going to build a function that's public, and
static. And it's just going to be void. So we're
going to modify the original input array. And what
I'm going to take in this is going to be called
merge sort. And it's going to take in just a one
dimensional integer array, and we'll call it data.
And it will have a start, and an end, which will
represent the indices that we're working with.
Now, for merge sort, this is going to be a
recursive call, we need to consider the base
cases. Remember, we work from the start
to the end. And if those values overlap,
then we've hit our base case. So we asked
this question, if start is less than end,
and we can continue doing work. But if the
start passes, whatever the end pointer is,
then there's no more work to continue.
We've already sorted the data.
And so remember, we're all about taking the
array and splitting it in two halves, we want to
divide the problem into two halves and solve them
independently. And so the first thing that we can
do is we can calculate the midpoint. And so what
we do is we say in mid is going to be basically
whatever the start index is of the array plus
the end index, and we divide that by two,
and that's going to be the
midpoint that we're working with.
And what do we want to do? Here, well, what
we want to do is we want to divide the array
in two parts. And so it would make sense for us to
just call merge sort. We're dealing with the same
data array. But our bounds are what has changed.
And so the start is again, for the first half
going to start at the same position, but
the end is going to end at the midpoint.
And that's going to be the left sub half.
Now, if we think about the right sub half,
the start is going to change, right? The start
is going to be whatever the midpoint is plus one,
all the way to the end. And this is how we can
consider splitting this array into two different
sub halves. But the question is, how do we how
do we merge this data, right, what we're doing
is we're just continuously dividing and dividing
and dividing, but I want to be able to merge the
data in sorted format. So let's build a function
called merge. And what merge is going to do,
it's going to take the original data array, and
it's going to start taking the start the midpoint
in the ending index. And remember that
last animation that we just looked at
does this kind of linear time comparison
to replace the values in the correct spot
when it's looking at the two sorted sub arrays, so
I build a function here, it's going to be public,
static void. And I'm just going to call this
merge. And again, it's going to take in an
integer array called data, a starting
point, a midpoint and an end point.
And now remember, we basically need to merge these
values, but I don't want to modify the input array
yet. So I'm going to build a temporary array. So
it would make sense to build a temporary array
to avoid modifying, can't type to avoid modifying
the original contents. And so in order for me to
do that, I can just build a simple temporary
array here. And it will be a new int array.
And the size is just going to be dependent on the
indices, right, so I have n minus start, plus one.
So this is going to build me a pre
allocated buffer of memory to hold
all the data for the sub arrays that I'm
dealing with, from the start and end index.
And now what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to copy the values. So I want to I
don't want to lose a reference to the start or
midpoint. So I'm going to say int i equals start,
we'll say j is equal to mid plus one, and k is
equal to zero. and k is going to be this kind
of tracker variable that we use to keep track
of the values that we put into this temporary.
So let's continue. Now recall back when we were
merging the data together in that final sub call,
that's a good way to kind of realize how this is
working. So we're basically doing a linear time
comparison, at the values in the left array, and
the pointer on the right array, and we're saying
which one is smaller, whichever one is smaller
is going to be placed first in this temporary.
And so I'm basically saying, while i is less
than or equal to mid, which is going to be
the left sub array. And we want to say,
well, j is less than or equal to the end,
then we can continue. And what is this
saying? What this is saying is while both
of the sub arrays have values, then
try and merge them in sorted order.
Right, and that's what we want to do. So
we're starting with I, which is the left
sub array up to the midpoint, and then j,
which starts from the midpoint to the end,
is going to be the right sub array. And
we just want to compare these values.
And so we ask a question, we say, Alright, well,
if data sub i is less than or equal to data sub j,
then we know what we know that the value in the
left sub array is less than whatever the value
is in the right sub array. So what we can do is
we can say, Alright, in this temporary buffer,
I'm going to put in at the index k data
sub i. So the smaller value gets put
next in the temporary. And now what I want
to do is I want to increment i, since I've
already placed it in the array, and I want to
increment K, so I don't override this value.
Now if this condition doesn't hold true,
then what I can say is well, okay, so
that would imply the opposite. So I would just
say temp of K is going to equal data sub J.
And then what we would do is we would say k plus
plus, and j plus plus. And you can also get fancy,
you can come in here and do something like k
plus plus here. And you can do something like
j plus plus here, it's both, it's going to be the
same thing. So if you want to simplify your code,
that way, you can do the post increment
operator to reduce the amount of code.
And this handles basically the comparison between
the sub arrays. But remember the conditional here,
the conditional says, we only do this while both
values have values to compare against. And the
example that we looked at, we actually ran out
of data in the left sub array. And we just had to
just blindly place all the data in the right sub
array into the original array. And so we need to
satisfy that case here. And in order to do that,
we can just say, while i is less than or equal to
the midpoint, so while there's basically data
to traverse, still, we're just going to place
it into the position of the temporary array
where it belongs. This would be data, so I,
and again, we would do k plus plus n i
plus plus. And that handles exhausting
the left sub array, if the right sub
array has run out of values, so we say,
add the rest of the values from the left sub
array into the result. Now on the opposite side,
if the left sub array has run out of values,
but we still have data in the right sub array,
then we just need to have the reverse conditional
and we say, while j is less than or equal to end,
then we're just gonna say temp
sub k is equal to data sub j.
And then again, we just increment K. And
we increment J. And this is the same thing,
we're adding the rest of the values from
the right sub array into the result.
You may ask, Are we done yet? And we're almost
done. But we need to remember we built this
temporary array, and this is void. And so we
haven't really done any work yet. And so the
question we need to ask is, how do we modify the
original data array in memory. Now, we don't want
to modify the entire array, we only want to modify
the subsection that we're dealing with right now,
in whatever recursive call that we're in. And
so this brings us to the copy phase, how do
we copy this data over from temp into the right
positions of the data, which is the original data.
And it turns out, we can just have a simple
for loop where we say i is equal to start.
And while i is less than end, right, so we're only
taking the subsection that we're dealing with.
So from start to end, right, which could be
any, any bounds at any point of the recursion.
So while I is equal to start n is less than or
equal to end, we're just going to increment i.
And in each iteration, we're going to load
up the original data array at the index i
to be equal to whatever's in the temporary
array at the value of i minus start.
So if the data array that we're dealing with, if
the start is 12, then what we would do is we would
say, all right, well, I equals 12. So 12 minus
star is zero. So we're going to load data set 12,
with whatever's at temp sub zero. And this
is the copy phase. This is how we actually
override values at each sub array.
Let's actually run some input here,
I'm going to have a new input array, we'll say,
you know, data equals new int. And we'll just load
it with some values, we'll say negative five,
you know, 2010 320. And what I want to do is
I want to sort this. So I'm going to call merge
sort. And I'm going to give it the data array,
the start is going to be the zeroeth index. And
the end is going to be the length minus one.
And so this should sort the array in place.
And so what I can do is I can put a breakpoint
to look at the array once it's been
sorted. And then we'll look at the
call stack to see what actually
is happening behind the scenes.
So I'm going to debug and we'll notice I
get here and merge sort has completed. And
what I can do is I can look at this stack frame
and look at the data. And you notice that we
have in the zeroeth index, negative 5023 10 and
20. And so this is the output in sorted order.
But this doesn't really do us any good unless
we understand what's happening at the level of
the call stack. So let's take a look at that.
By put a breakpoint in the merge sort function.
Let's kind of look and see what's happening. If
I dive in here, the first stack frame gets added
to the call stack for merge sort. And I basically
ask is start less than end? And the answer is no,
we still have work to do. And so when I go in
here, I calculate the midpoint. And I say I want
to divide this array into two sub halves. And the
midpoint here is two. And so what I do is I say,
Alright, I'm going to divide everything from
zero to two into its own set of sub arrays,
and then I'll handle the right half. And remember,
I can't even go to the right half until the left
half has completed. So I dive into this. And
now I'm looking at everything from zero to two.
And I have to break this up even further. And
so now I'm at this position where the midpoint
is one. And again, I grow the call stack,
and I'm still only on the left hand side.
And I calculate the midpoint again, and I
go again. And now we don't satisfy this,
right, because zero and zero are equal. And
so we actually pop this off the call stack.
And now we return to the next recursive
call. And the next recursive call says,
Okay, now I want to handle
the right hand side of this,
right. And when I dive into this, I grow the call
stack again. And again, we pop off, right, we
don't satisfy this base case, and we kind of just
continue this operation. And so now I've reached
the basically the base case on the far left hand
side of the first left sub half of this array.
And what it's asking me to do is it's asking
me to now merge these values in sorted order.
So if I dive in here, and we look at the merge,
let's analyze the start the mid and the end.
Remember, I'm only dealing
with basically two values here.
And so if I go in here, we have a temporary
array, and it's only of size two. And that's
because my base case here for merge sort is only
really comparing two values. And so we go in here,
and we say, all right, which one's smaller, the
left value, or the right value. And I come in
here, and I say, Okay, well, here, the left value
is smaller. So I load up K, I load up temp, and I
put in negative five. And then I have another
while loop. And remember, because I ran out of
values to compare in the left sub array, I need
to basically take all the values in the right sub
array and put them in the positions they belong.
So I come down here and I load up the values,
increment the counters. And now we're
done, because we've hit this base case.
So now, I have this sorted sub array, negative
five and 20. And what do I need to do I need to
put these in the original spot, right? If we look
at these values, I have, you know, I, J and K.
What does that mean? Well, it means that
from the position that I'm dealing with,
in the original array, I need to override those
values. So that's what this replacement is
going to do. So coming here, I replaced value
one, I replace value two. And now I'm done.
And that is the process that we go through
for a single iteration of merge sort. And
this process will basically continue as
we are dealing with bigger and bigger sub
arrays as we recurse back from the bottom
up, right, and now we're merging again.
And notice, like, since we did the left sub half,
which was just two values, now we're dealing with
the right sub half, right. And now we have three
values, and the right sub half of another sub
problem. And so we just continue comparing and
going up and going up. Now, we won't go through
every stack frame. In this call. There are quite
a few as we saw in the animation. But I encourage
you to rewatch that animation because that is
the order that the call stack will be evaluated.
And that's the order in which things will recurs
back up from the subproblems to get merged into
some overall solution. And that's one of
the key components of divide and conquer.
linkless are really common data structures used
to store data that is not necessarily contiguously
stored in memory. And it turns out, you can do a
lot of cool recursion on these sorts of things.
We're going to look at link list reversal.
And we'll look at an animation to walk through
this code. Now the idea is that we have some
sort of linked list. Let's say we have values
in sorted order like this. And we'll just have a
bunch of pointers. And the idea is that the head
node changes from one pointing to two pointing to
345. Instead, we want six to point toward five,
five, to point toward four, and so on. And when
we look at this code, this reversal code, we asked
this question, all right, if the head node is
null, right, if we pass in a null value, or the
next value from the head is null, then we just
return the head. And this kind of brings us back
to that idea of considering base cases. What's the
smallest thing I could pass in? If I passed in?
No, then I can just return null. And that would
be a reversed list. Right? And in the same vein,
if I passed in just a single node, where there was
no next node, then I could just return head again.
And those are good base cases for this solution.
But the question is, how do I even start the
reversal? What's the unit of work I need to
do and that's what we're going to look at.
So we start with one, the head node that we
pass in on the first iteration is one. And we
don't hit the base case. And so on line three, we
see that we call reverse list head dot next. And
that immediately pushes us to the next node.
And we have one stack frame on the call stack.
Now we're looking at two and this, this is not
know either, and it also doesn't have a pointer
pointing to null. And so we execute line three,
again at another stack frame on the call stack.
And that gets us to three. And this process
continues all the way until we get to six.
And when six gets passed in as a parameter,
we say is it null? And the answer's no,
but the next value is null. And so what
do we return, what we do is we return
head, which is just six, and six gets returned
as the node to the previous value. So this is
the base case. And we return this to five. And
so now P has been evaluated to the number six.
And what we're saying since since the number
five is the current head node, we're saying
five dot next dot next, equals five. And it turns
out that what that means is we're basically just
saying, Okay, well, what I want you to do
is take six and have it point back to five,
because head next to six, and head dot next, which
is six dot next, is going to be pointing to five.
And if that doesn't make sense, I encourage
you to really slow down and read this code.
And think five is the head node. And we want
to say the next pointers, next position just
points back to ourself. Now the problem here
is that five is is also pointing to six.
And if we were to trace this, this is this would
be a cyclic dependency. And this would never end
right. And so what we can do is we can just say
fives dot next, can point to nothing, right? This
is no, and so that gets dropped off. And what we
return is we return six, because we want six to be
the new head. And so six will just get propagated
down the call stack to the original color to be
the new head node. And that's why we return p
here. And so now we return and we get to four.
And when we look at four, we know that P is
six. And what we're asking here is we're saying
fours, next note is five, and I want five
2.4. And so again, we do the same thing,
we take five, eight points to four. And to avoid
the cyclic dependency, we drop this pointer here,
this connection. And what do we return?
What will you turn six, because again,
six gets propagated through, and six is always
going to be P in this case. And so now I return.
And I know six is P, but head dot next is four.
And so I want for 2.23. So I say head dot next dot
next equals three. So I draw a pointer. And again,
I dropped the cyclic dependency and I get rid of
this connection. And now I return, P is still six,
I return to two and I say two's next value, which
is three, I want three dot next to point to two.
So we do this, I dropped the pointer and I return.
And then finally we do this again. I dropped
the pointer and now we're done. So let's let's
take the opportunity to look at the call stack
and really understand how this is
working in a little bit more detail.
In order to save some time I've written some
code. The first piece of code I want to look
at is this idea of a node. Now this node
is just an abstraction that holds a value
and a pointer to The next node. And so this is
the easiest way to build a singly linked list.
Now, I also made a method called print link list.
And this will just print all the values. And this
is a verification that we can use to ensure
that we've reversed the linked list correctly.
And the final thing I want to look at is
the actual code. So this is the same code
that was on the slide. And I want to look
at the call stack as we debug through this.
So I have a singly linked list here 12345, just
as we looked at, and they're all linked together.
And what we want to do is we want
to actually see how the reversal
is working. So if I run and debug this,
we're going to look at the call stack.
So the first thing I hit is this call. And you'll
notice in the stack frame, as I dive into this
function, this is the initial stack frame that
gets put onto the call stack. And ask myself,
is the node that I'm looking at, which is
one, is it No, and the answer is no. is the
next value? No, the answer's no, it's
two, right. And we can see that here.
So I continue through. And I just call reverse
list again, which is a recursive call. And as
a dive into this, I add another stack frame to
the call stack. And now you see my values too.
And my next note is still not
know. So I continue through.
And I add another recursive call, which
adds another stack to the stack frame
to the call stack. And I continue. And
this process is going to keep continuing.
Now notice here, the value is five, but my next
value is actually null. And that satisfies this
base case here. So if we continue, you notice
I just return null here. And this stops the
recursion. So notice this stack frame should get
popped off. So as I continue through, that stack
frame gets removed. And now I'm looking at four.
And it actually shows me what the result of this
recursive call was for P. So as I step over,
we can look at p and see that P is just five.
And so I'm basically saying the node dot
next, so let's evaluate that. So node dot next
has a value of five. And I'm basically saying I
want five two point. So I want five dot next 2.2,
whatever my current value is, which
is four, right? So we know no dot Val
is four. So I'm changing the pointers
here. So as I step over, now I have four
pointing to know as I execute this, so we step
over one more. So as I look@no.val.no dot next,
there should be no which it is. And now the value
P which was five should be pointing to for now.
So P dot next, dot Val is four. Right.
And so the whole idea here is that now
we return the very last note again,
and we pop this off the call stack.
And the node that we're looking at at this point
is three. And right now three is pointing to four,
right? So if we look at no dot Val, which is
three, we can say no dot next dot Val, and this
is four. But this is wrong, right? Because we
want for it to be pointing to three, not three
pointing to four. And so that's what this line
is doing. I'm saying I want four to point back
to three. And so I do that, and then I drop
the connection. And so now if I evaluate this,
and we look at p, we can actually see the progress
that we've made five points to four, and four
points to three. Okay, so we're not done yet. But
we're making progress. And as we return from here,
we pop off the call stack. And we just keep doing
this process. We return we pop up the call stack,
we come appear we return and we pop up the call
stack. And now we're back to the original call.
And remember how we propagated the very
last value throughout all these calls. So
as we look at the reverse value, reverse dot
Val, it's five and this is our new head node,
which was the goal of this problem. And so if we
come in we look at reverse, we say okay, we have
five the next value is for the next value. There's
three the next value, there's two and an x value.
There's one, and then we're complete. And so this
is how the call stack works for a linked list
reversal. A really fun problem to consider with
linked lists is how do you merge two sorted linked
lists recursively. We're going to look at how the
call stack works for this Let's analyze this small
snippet of code and see if we can conceptualize
what's happening on the call stack. We take in
two head nodes. One was a list of values, and the
other is a singly linked list of values as well.
And we asked this question, the first question
is, what's the smallest input I could pass in?
And that's a good consideration for our base case,
the same formula that we've been applying. If I
pass in a head node for a, that's no, then I can
just return b, because B would be merged with no,
which would just be itself. And in the same
vein, if b is null, and I merge that with a,
then I can just return a. And if they're both
No, then no merge with no is also just the null
value. So this holds true. And that's the base
case. But let's consider the other side of things.
And this is kind of a similar
comparison that we saw with merge sort.
Right now we're considering, Okay, first of
all, base case. But second of all, what's the
unit of work that we need to do the recursion.
And I think it'll help if we look at two lists.
So we have two sorted lists of values. And
we want to go through this recursive call.
And the first thing that we do is we
add a stack frame to the call stack.
And it basically says, the head nodes that I have
are one and four, so neither of them are null.
And what I want to do is I want to say,
all right, which which value is smaller,
the value in the first node or the
value in the second node A or B,
A's data is one and B's data is four. So that
first conditional is the one that will be
recursive upon. And I basically say one dot next
is going to be pointing to sorted sorted merge.
And node A is going to be incremented by one
value, so I add another stacker into the call
stack. And so now I pass in eight. And now he is
getting compared with four. And we still haven't
hit our base case, right. And so I look at the
L statement. And I compare eight and four and
four is obviously smaller. And so this is
going to be the next node that I consider.
And I just continue this process.
So now eight and 11 gets compared,
instance eight is smaller, and I pass in 22. And
I add another stack frame. And now 22, and 11,
get compared. And since 11 is smaller, I pass in
the node right after 11. And these get compared.
And notice in the calls, the recursion needs to
complete, but I'm actually setting these results
as the next value. And so as we compare
22 and 1616 is smaller, so I pass in 20.
And now 20 is smaller. But it's interesting
because there is no node after 20.
And so now I'm at this point where I have
no. And now we consider the base case,
if we have a null value, which is B in this case,
then I just returned a. And if I return a then I'm
just returning the reference to the node of 22. So
here's the base case. And what I can do is I can
just simply return 22 here, and
this gets popped off the call stack.
And this is where the unravelling starts
to begin. So when I return 22 here,
I actually change 20s dot next pointer, right,
because I'm saying 20 dot next, is equal the
result of sorted merge. And since sorted, merge
returned 22, I can now modify this pointer.
And from here, I return a. And when
I return a I'm just returning 20.
And this gets popped off the call stack.
And now, you know we're looking at 16. And we're
saying what should sixteens next pointer be? Well,
16 should point to 20. But it already is pointing
to 20. So we don't really need to do anything.
And so I returned from here 16. And
this gets popped off the call stack.
And again in the same in the same case,
11 is already pointing to 16. So we don't
need to modify anything. But we return 11 from
here and this gets popped off the call stack.
And now we have this question eight was pointing
to 22. But since we returned to 11, we can now
say that eight is going to point to 11. And that
means we modify the pointer, which we've done.
Right, and now we return eight from
this stack frame, a smaller value,
and this gets popped off the call stack.
Now we compare eight and four four was
pointing to 11. But since eight got
returned from the recursive call,
and we take four and we point it to eight now we
return the smaller value From the stack frame.
And what do we do here? Well, what happens
here is we pop this off the call stack,
and four is the smaller value. And so now what
we want is we want one to point to the four node.
And this is our final stack frame. And from
here, we just return one, which is the head node,
which is the smallest value from the two sorted
lists. And from here, this gets popped off the
stack frame. And if we follow these edges, or
these pointers, we noticed one goes to four goes
to eight goes to 11, to 16, to 20, to 22, to
40. And this ends up being our sorted list.
And even for this, we can take a second to
look at the code and understand the call stack.
Alright, so I've gone ahead and I've actually
built a couple linkless. So we have one here.
So one, 513 14, and 550. And we have another
completely independent link lists to 15 130
203 50. And the idea here is how do we take
these and merge them in their sorted order.
And so we take the same code
that we were just looking at,
but now we want to analyze it from the call stacks
perspective. And so I'm going to come over here,
and I'm going to put a breakpoint on the initial
call. And we're going to debug into this function.
So as I dive into this function, you'll notice
the call stack grows. And now we have two lists,
this would be a and b from the example. So we
have one and two. And this corresponds to the
two initial nodes that we have here, two and one.
And what we're doing is we're checking if you know
the first list is null, then we return the second
list. And if the second list is null, we return
the first list. This, of course, does not hold
true yet. So we continue and compare the values.
Since one is less than two, we jump in here
and we do another recursive call. And notice
that we pass in the next value that one
was pointing to, but two stays the same.
And we continue this comparison. Now since five is
greater than two, we go to the second conditional,
and we do a recursive call. And notice
the stack frames are just growing.
They're just growing. And this stack frame is
dependent on the result of this stack frame.
And as I continue through and do these
comparisons, I have another stack frame.
And each subsequent stack frame has a dependency
on the results of whichever one is above it.
And so we keep doing this. And we do this
until we hit one of these base cases.
So I continue through. And
now I've hit a base case,
the value that we have is list one, which is 550.
And I'm just going to return this. And when I
return it, what happens? Well, it's the result of
this function. So I say l to Next is 550. And when
that gets evaluated, I just return here. And you
notice that the stack frames will start shrinking
now because we've hit a base case. And so as I
continue through, and I'm returning these values,
you'll notice that our call stack is shrinking in
size. And we're basically reassigning the pointers
to the next node. And it shrinks and shrinks and
shrinks. And now finally, we get to a point where
the sorted operation is complete. And so if we
look at sorted merge, if we look at this value,
we noticed that the first value is one, the next
value is two 513. And it's now in sorted order. So
we've taken two sorted lists and merge them in
ascending order, which is the expected output.
And this is just an example of taking two linked
lists and showing how the merge operation works
on the call stack. This brings me to one
of my favorite topics, which is trees.
And trees are one of the really fantastic data
structures that work really well with recursion.
And the first question we're going to look at
is inserting a value into a binary search tree.
Now a tree for especially a binary search
tree is going to be a series of nodes and
we're going to basically start from the top
down, we're gonna have a bunch of connections,
and the number of children at most that
we can have from a single notice to
and the least amount of nodes you can have
is zero. And so what we're going to do is
we're going to add a bunch of numbers here
and analyze the properties of this tree.
Notice that everything to the left of the root
node 100 is less than 100. And everything to the
right is greater than 100. Now this property it
turns out holds true recursively. So if we look
at at everything to the left is less than 80.
Everything to the right is greater than eight
But it's interesting because everything
to the right is greater than 80,
but also still less than 100. And so if you
look, the largest value on the subtree of 80,
on the right subtree is 95. And 95 is still less
than 100. And so if you're not familiar with the
properties of binary search trees, I encourage
you to just do a quick, quick look and look at
the rules for that. But this is pretty much
the entire rule set for a binary search tree.
And we're faced with this task and the task
is to add this node, and the node is 108.
And if we look at this value, we basically say,
Okay, I'm going to start at the top of this tree,
and I'm going to figure out where can I place 108.
And I compare I say, is 108, greater than 100,
or less than 100? or equal to 100? And I
say it's greater than, so I go to the right.
And I ask is 108 greater than 120, or
less than less than or equal to 120?
And we see it's less than so I go to
the left sub half. And I asked the
same question is 100, a greater than 110 or
less than 110. And I see it the less than,
and so now I go down here. And I draw connection.
And this is the point where 108 belongs.
And here you can see it's its sale still satisfies
the rule set, right? 108 is greater than 100.
So it satisfies that property, it's less than
120. It's less than 110. So this is the valid
position for 108. And so let's look at the code.
Turns out the code for this is extremely simple.
And like I had said, before we consider the base
case, what's the smallest thing I can pass in?
Well, what if there is no root? Right? What if
this is the first value that we're inserting
into the tree? Well, if that's the case,
then what I do is I just create a new node,
I set the data, and I return that value. Right?
And it turns out, that's a fairly good base case.
Now, if we consider the other case, now we
need to start thinking about, okay, well,
what if I need to do some comparisons? And this
is where I start comparing the data. So let's look
at what's happening. The first
question says, If I hit null,
I've recurse to my end goal, according to the
search tree properties of the binary search tree.
Now remember, binary search tree node, insertions
will always happen at the leaf level. So they
always happen at the end. So if you've done
all your comparisons until the very end,
then you've hit a valid position to insert
the data. Right? And that valid position
would be when you have no more comparisons to
do, which is implied by the head node B, no.
Now the next conditional I look at is
basically saying, Okay, I'm at a node,
and I want to compare it to my current node.
So remember, when we were comparing 108 to 100,
I asked this question I say, is the node i want
to insert greater or less than this value. If it's
greater than I say, head dot right equals, and
then I just make another recursive call. And I
progress to either the left or right half of the
subtree. The other side is just the opposite. So
if I'm less than the current node, then I want
to go down the left hand side of the sub tree.
Now, this final piece right here, is, once I've
done all this work, I've done all the insertions,
I just want to return the original root node.
And that original root node just says basically,
here's the tree that you started with.
Let's look at the call stack.
During this insertion process.
I call insert node. And I'm comparing 100 and
108. And I know 108 is greater than 100. So I
recurse down the right hand side. Now when I get
to this point, I add another stack frame. And I'm
comparing 120 and 108. And I know 108 is now less
than this. So I recurse down the left hand side.
Now here, I'm comparing 108 and 110. Add
another stack frame, I compare these values.
And because it's less than
I go to the left hand side.
And this is interesting, because now
my value that I compare against is no.
And remember, when we look at the code here, no is
just the base case. This is what we consider when
we insert a node. And so I just create that
108 node and I return it right. And so here
is where I would say, okay, new node had died
data equals 108. And I would return this node.
And so from this stack frame, I would actually
return the 108 node and pop this off the stack.
And what I would do here because I was saying
110 dot left, equals whatever that value was.
Now I can draw connection to 108 and just
start returning those values up the stack.
And that's the process of inserting
a value into a binary search tree.
Let's look at another fun problem, which is also
a kind of a fun depth first tree reversal problem.
And the purpose here is to print all the leaf
nodes. So we're looking at the same tree.
But we want to build a function
that prints out all the nodes
that we see here in the order from left
to right. So 30 6080 590-510-8115 and 150.
Now if we think about the recursion for how this
works, mechanically, we start at the root node,
and we go all the way down. And we hit a
leaf node here, so we would print it out.
And what I would do is I would basically
pop off the call stack and go to this node.
But I would immediately go to this nodes, right
subtree. And this would be another leaf node
because it has no children. And I would print
this and recurse up the stack. And then I would
go back up to 80. And now go down, it's right
half. And here, I'll go down its left sub half,
find a leaf node return, go down the right sub
half, find a leaf node return. And this process
just continues. And the order of execution is
really important to understand here. Remember,
if I'm going down the left sub half, I can't
even consider the right sub half until the left
sub half has been fully explored. And that's
part of the property that depth first search
follows. And we'll look at another DFS example
with a graph in just a second. So now I go down,
I recurse down the left sub half, I find the leaf
node I print it, I recurse back up and do this
all the way until I'm basically out of leaf nodes
to find which brings us here. And now we're done.
So here's the code for this. And
we'll look at this to understand
how things get added on the call stack as
well in the code. But again, our base cases,
what happens if we pass in a null value,
that's a pretty good base case, right?
Because then we would just return there's
nothing to print if you just pass a null.
But we also have to think about the
goal, the goal is to print the leaf node.
And so we want to keep recursing
until we hit a leaf node.
And the properties of a node being a leaf node is
that there are no children. And so this is where
we start to ask, okay, if there are no children
to the left, there are no children to the right,
then I can actually evaluate the underlying
value of that node and just return.
Now, if we're not a leaf node, then we need
to recurse down the left sub half of the tree,
which is what we're doing here. And if
we have a right sub half to recurse,
then we go down the right sub half after the
left sub half has been explored. So this allows
us again, this is why we evaluate the left hand
side first. And then we go down the right hand
side recursively. And we do that for all recursive
sub trees up until we're done. So let's look at
the call stack and see how this is executing,
or we're looking at here is the same program. So
we have some code here, print leaves, and it's
the same code that we looked at before. So if
the input root node is null, we just return, we
evaluate the left and right. And this basically
checks if a given node is a belief. And we print
it, and then we pop ourselves off the call stack.
Now if we don't satisfy that, then we go
down the left and right half the subtree.
So using the same code that we looked
at for insertion, I've actually built
up a tree to use. So I have some input with
a bunch of numbers. These are all the numbers
that we were looking at before I believe. And it's
just a random set of numbers. So nothing special.
And we just insert them. So I have a function here
from the previous example called insert node. And
it just builds us a tree for us. And so now what I
want to do is I want to print all the leaves here.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to add a
breakpoint here. And we're going to debug straight
into it. And the first question I asked is, is the
root node? No. And the answer is no, it's not No.
Right? So this first value. And so what do I do?
Well, I recurse down the entire left half of the
subtree. So remember, it starts at 100. And now
I go down to the left. And since it's not No,
I skip over this. And now I just recurse down the
left half of the tree. And for that node, again,
it's not know. And for that specific node i again
recurse down to the left sub half of the tree.
And I just keep going down the left
half I don't even explore the right half
until this level. Tap has been fully explored.
And you notice we just printed out the first
leaf node, which is 30. And it's only until I
explored that entire sub trees left half, that I
can now go to this other sub trees right half. So
I dive in here. And now I go down the right half.
It turns out that the right half again,
is just another leaf node. And so I can
just print this value. And if I put a breakpoint
here, you'll notice that we just keep printing.
You know, we hit Knowles, we hit
Knowles, and we print the leaves.
And you can see down here, this is the
leaf node evaluation that we're doing.
And the reason I wanted to walk through
this animation is just further emphasize
that when we're thinking about the call stack, I
cannot even consider evaluating this expression
until every recursive call, and every
sub call has been fully evaluated.
Once that holds true, then I can start unraveling
the right sub trees and I work from the bottom up.
And that's the idea for these kind of
DFS traversals that we're dealing with.
This brings us to our last section of algorithms
that we'll be looking at. And we'll look at a
simple example with graphs. And we'll just see
how similar working with graphs is to something
like trees. And we're going to look at a very
popular algorithm known as depth first search.
And the idea is that we start at a node like a,
and we basically say we're searching for a node,
let's say the node we're searching for is H.
And so I start from a and I say, Okay, let me
get all the neighbors and see is this my value,
so a is not my value. So I go to my neighbor,
and I say B, B is not my value, go to C, D is not
my value, but I get all my neighbors. And this is
at an interesting point, because I'm searching
for H, right, which is in the far half. But when
I get my neighbor's, let's say the first neighbor
I get is E. And so I actually have to explore down
the depths of E before I even consider going to H.
And so I go down, and I see E. And now I go to F.
And now I have to look at all of F's
neighbors. So the first neighbor I go to is K.
And if k had neighbors, I would
explore all of those neighbors.
But it doesn't, so I can just pop off. And now I
go to J and back to F. Now I go to I am back to F,
and I kind of recurse backup the call stack.
So now that I've explored all the neighbors of
right, I've explored one neighbor of D, I
only have one unvisited neighbor left for
me to explore. And it's g so I go to G and I
say is this the value that I'm looking for?
And it's not. So I look at the neighbors of G
and I say is this the value I'm looking for?
And it is. And this is the idea of depth first
search. And so we're going to look at a piece
of code and walk through it line by line and see
how something like this would work recursively.
We look at a piece of code like
this, and we have the input node.
And to avoid cycles, which can happen in graphs,
which is different than trees will keep a set
of visited values. So we never want to visit the
same node more than once. And so that's what the
visited set is going to do. And the goal integer
here is just the node that we're looking for.
So I know the graph we were just looking at was
letters, but we're going to assume that we're
working with a graph with integer values. And we
ask our base case questions again. So think about
the smallest thing you could pass in if you pass
in an empty node, a normal node, then there's no
way you could ever find the goal, because the
goal is an integer value. And so here, we would
just return false. So this is a base case. The
other base case is if we've actually found the
node. So let's assume the node you pass in is the
gold node, then here we found the node. And so we
would just return true here, and this would imply
that we found the value that we're looking for.
But let's assume that we haven't found the
value, just like the example. The first thing
that we need to do is we need to aggregate all
of the neighbors from a given node. And so we're
going to assume the node API has a function call
that allows you to aggregate all the neighbors.
And the first question we ask is have
we have we visited this node before?
Remember, we want to avoid cycles. And so we
never want to visit a node more than once.
And so if it's been visited, we just ignore it
and we continue. But if it hasn't been visited,
then we add it to the visited set. And we start
the exploration. And we ask this question,
have we found the node that we've been working
with with this particular neighbor. If we've
found the solution, then we can just return
right away. Now if we haven't found the solution
from this particular neighbor, then we'll continue
recursing through the rest of the neighbors
And it's at that point, if we found it, we would
return true. And this brings us to our last base
case, let's assume that we've traversed all of
the neighbors. And we never found the solution.
That would mean that the goal value that we're
looking for was just never in the graph to begin
with. And this brings us to our final base case
of just returning false. And this is a way to say,
hey, I've searched for this node, but it
didn't exist in the graph. It's false,
it did not show up in the search. And
that's where we can terminate the algorithm.
I think it's important to spend just a little
bit of time talking about optimizations that
you can make when using recursion. And
the first that we're going to look at is
memoir, zation. And caching, which we
talked about briefly when writing Fibonacci.
And the question that we're trying to answer here
is how can we speed up our program by pretty much
storing things that we've already re computed or
computed for the first time. So if I've computed
some very expensive operation, and I have to re
compute it again, in a subsequent recursive call,
I want to check to see if I've done
that work already. And if I have,
I'm just going to return the result instead
of re computing that operation again.
And the best way to kind of conceptualize This
is looking at the Fibonacci tree sequence.
Here, we see that I'm doing F of three twice,
and I'm re computing F of two, three times.
And the question is, why can't I just compute
f of two once, and then just reuse that value,
so I don't grow these sub trees. And it
turns out, you can do that really easily.
Let's look at the modified Fibonacci code. Notice
I have a hashmap here and hashmaps have this
property, such that we can retrieve values from
the map in constant time access, so big O of one.
And the reason is because the data that we
put into the hashmap is hashed. And so we have
constant time access to the memory addresses
in which that data is stored. And so when I
call the Fibonacci function, the first thing
I always do is I say, Hey, does the cache have
this value. And you can also notice that I've pre
populated the cache with the base cases as well.
Now in the instance, that the cache does not have
the value, I still go about the recursive call,
as I had done previously. But I ensure that
once that recursive call has been evaluated,
I put the result into the cache.
And then I return my result.
And this is a really key component because
the cache is global, right. And so all the
subsequent recursive calls are putting their
results in the cache. And as things get added,
and popped off the stack, I can just keep
cross referencing the cache to see if I'm
doing redundant work or not. And that saves me
a lot of computational power. So that's the idea
of memorization and caching. And you can do a
lot of this in a lot of different situations.
The next optimization I want to just discuss is
this idea of tail call recursion optimization. And
people usually refer to this as you know,
tail call optimization, or tail recursion.
And the idea here is that basically, the compiler
in certain languages, especially functional
programming languages, will optimize the number of
stack frames that get added to the call stack to
basically remove this idea of stack
overflows in a lot of scenarios.
Now, the way that the compiler does this analysis
is it really looks at the last function call.
And it has to be a recursive call. And we'll
look at an idea of comparing these two things.
And there was actually a response on the
computer science Stack Exchange by this user,
and he gave two examples. The first is
this simple recursive factorial function.
And notice that the final return value is a
value multiplied by a recursive call. Now,
this is not tail recursive, because the return
value is not just the recursive call. And so in
order for this to be tail recursive optimized,
we need to modify to look something like this.
Now, if you spend a second to look at this
code, you'll realize that functionally it's
doing the exact same thing. But we've had
to modify the parameters to get to a point
where we can build a function that's tail call
optimized. And the reason it's optimized with this
tail call recursive property is because the final
return value is in itself just a recursive call.
And it turns out in certain operating in certain
languages, in their compilers, they've implemented
some optimization techniques to exploit
this property and reduce stack overflows.
Now, I just want to make a couple notes
on this. The rule of thumb is to always
make your recursive calls be the last instruction
Nothing gets added to it, just the recursive call.
And the other thing to consider is that this is
supported mostly by functional languages. But it's
not inherent in languages like Python and Java and
even JavaScript. There are certain browsers for
ies 2016. They do support tail call recursion
optimization for things like JavaScript,
but it's not supported across the board. And so
as you're considering this optimization technique,
think about what language you're using. And think
about, you know, the compiler that you're using
and where your code is being executed to see if
this sort of optimization is supported or not.
So this brings us to our final slide. What's
next? And when we ask this question, it's really
to consider like how far do you want to go in
your journey of recursion. And that brings us to
another video that we'll have coming out, known
as algorithmic mental models for backtracking.
And this is the entire notion that we basically
solve even more complex problems by looking at a
decision space and recursively going through
and seeing if our decision was good or bad,
and backtracking to see if we can
solve the solution in a different way.
And that's the next phase that I think
is important for understanding recursion.
So thank you guys so much for watching. Be sure
to check out my channel youtube.com slash the
symbol engineer and connect with me on youtube
or Twitter or LinkedIn. And I'd be happy to talk
with you and answer any questions you may have.
So thanks, guys for watching and have a good day.